ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนหากเจอ
กันอีกแล้วคลิปทิสามละเนาะใช่ค่ะที่ 3
อ่า Begin ได้แล้ววัน
ให้ขากูเรียมแข็งแรงดีไหมคะครูเรียมแข็ง
แรงดีค่ะแล้วครูเอ๋นะคะทั้งแรงดีค่ะ
กว่าดีนะค่ะคุณเรียมวันนี้เดี๋ยว Skin ดี
ไหมจะเขียน
เดี๋ยวครูเรียมลองแชร์สปริง
ลองแหได้ค่ะ
ว้าวมาแล้วค่ะมาแล้วอ่ะอ่ะกูเรียมวันนี้
วันอะไรคะแต่วันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวัน
พฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์
ได้ไหม
ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋เห็นใช่ไหมคะเห็นค่ะเห็นเห็น
น่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
5  5
วันที่ 5 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือน
พฤศจิกายนขายค่ะเดือนที่ 11 เนาะ
11.5 ราคาตาอะแล้ว
10.2 อะไรคะเพราะสอนอ่ะคะผชคุยเขียนผช
หายพ.ต.
2556  4 ยินดีค่ะให้
2564 หรือพูด 2,000
564 นะคะข้อ 2 อะอะไรคะคุณเรียมคอต
โต้ยิงพัน
21 ค่ะขอ
2021 นะคะอ่ะใช่คลิปนี้ครูเรียมกับครู
เอ๋เรคคอร์ดวีดีโอวันศุกร์แปลว่าวีดีโอจะ
ออกน่าจะวันอาทิตย์นะให้เพราะวันนี้วัน
ที่ 5 นะคะวันศุกร์เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เดี๋ยวก็เอกเขียนได้ไหมเมื่อวานนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีเมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดีนะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ค่ะวันที่ 4 นะ
คะเดือนมีอะไรคะครูเรียมเดือนพฤศจิกายน
เดือนพฤศจิกายนปีพตเท่าไหร่คะ
2564 ค่ะ 2000
2564 ดีขอเท่าไหร่คะมีคศ
2000  21 ค่ะ 2021 นะคะ
โคเรียมคะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
นี้วันศุกร์นะคะเมื่อวานนี้เมื่อวานนี้
วันพฤหัสบดี
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะวัน
เสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6 วันที่ 6
นะคะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือนพฤศจิกายนนี้นะคะปีพตเท่า
ไหร่คะ
2564 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ
2010  21 นะคะคุณเรียมลบเนาะอยากเดี๋ยว
กูเองเป็นคนแช่สกรีนเองเนาะทรายค่ะๆๆอัน
นี้ไปก่อนนะคะ
จิ๊นเอ๊ะเดี๋ยววันนี้นักเรียนวันนี้นะครู
เรียมกับกูอีกจะมาแข่งกัน
วาดรูป
แข็งกายเลยค่ะนั้นก่อนไปไหนคะเราจะวาดรูป
อะไรคะเดี๋ยวกู a ให้ดูอ่ะคู๋เมนิราคา
แม่
เกศจะมีอันที่ 1 นะคะโพเรียมค่ะหนึ่งอะ
เป็นเป็นสถานที่ทั้งหมดเลยค่ะกูเรียมสถาน
ที่ก็คืออันที่ 1 บ้าน
[เพลง]
บ้านสาขา
บ้านอันที่ 2
วัด
อ๋อ
นะคะ
อ่านบอกฉันอันที่สามยี่ทรายคะอ่าเป็น
ห้าง
ข้างอ่ะ
ก็จะเป็นเดอะมอลล์เซ็นทรัลห้างอะไรก็ได้
นะคะถ้าเป็นห้างนะคะมีอีกค่ะโคเรียมมีที่
ไหนอีกคะอันที่ 4 เป็น
ของเขาภูเขา
เชียงใหม้เชียงรายที่ไหนก็ได้ภูเขานะคะ
อันที่ 5
ทะเล
อ๋ออ๋อทะเล
ภูเก็ตมัลดีฟฮาวายทะเล
อะอะเอาอะไรอีกดี
อันที่ 6 และกันอันที่หกอะไรคะเป็นถนน
ถนน
ถนนในกรุงเทพคะแล้วก็ใกล้ๆถนนแถวนี้
มีมี 6 นะคะโหงานคืนหนึ่งบ้านนะคะ 2 วัด
สามอาห้างข้างนะคะข้าง
อารมณ์บินสันห้างเซ็นทรัลห้าง The  Mall
ห้างสยามพารากอน
ห้างที่ไทย
ต่อไปก็เป็น
ภูเขาม้าๆค่ะแล้วก็ทะเลราคาแล้วก็ถนน
เดี๋ยวคู๋มีคนเรียนมีกระดาษเขียนมี kaa
เขียนนะอันนี้หนึ่งนะคะทุเรียนค่ะเอกพับ
แล้วก็มือ
สองราคา
ค่ะเว็บครับ
ผู้เรียนจะเลือกได้ไหม
แล้วก็
สาวนะคะ 3  OA พับ
ครับแล้วก็
4 ราคา 4 ค่ะเอกกับครับ
แล้วก็
555 ตัวเองกลับครับ
6 ค่ะ
เม้นต์ไว้บ่อ
พัก
แล้วพี่เอ๋จัดเลือกมา 1 อันหรอคะ
คู๋จะจะให้คุยอยู่ที่นี่ใช่มั้ยโอเคมีก็
มีมือมือขวาเนี่ย 3 เบอร์มือซ้าย
3 นะคะฮ่าๆให้ค่ะให้คุณเรียมเลือกก่อน
เอาขวาหรือซ้าย
เอาขวาค่ะขวางั้นซ้ายคุยวานนะ
r3e  3 ใช่ไหมคะมีไส้ค่ะอ่ากูเตรียมเอา
ขวากลางสายเห็นไหมค่ะ
อันนี้ปลาหาอันนี้กว่านะคะ R กลาง
สาย
อะไรคะ
ขวากลางซ้ายโพเรียมขวาคุยนักเรียนขวาคู๋
ผู้เตรียมเลือกปรางเอากลางนะคะอ่าค่ะงั้น
2 อันหนัง x เก็บนะ
นักเรียนเกมนี้นะคะครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋
เนี่ยต้องดูอันนี้ Number อะไรแล้วก็ต้อง
วาดว่านัมเบอร์นั้นมีอะไรสองคนแข่งกันนะ
คะติ๊กตอกติ๊กตอกเกรียมคูเรียมชอบอะไรชอบ
บ้านวัดข้างภูเขาทะเลถนน
ชอบคู่เขาค่ะชอบภูเขาใช่ไหมคะภูเขาเบอร์ 4
ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอันนี้เบอร์อะไรซึ่งตอนเป็น
ตึกๆๆเบอร์เบอร์ C ไหม 4 ไว้เบอร์ 4
เบอร์ 4 เบอร์ 4 เบอร์ 4
โอ้ยเบอร์ 3
เบอร์ 3 เบอร์ 3 เป็นห้างนะคะงั้นเรานะก็
จะไปนะคะค่ะ
โอเคห้าง
ก็จะเป็น
อันนี้เหลี่ยม
ขอโทษค่ะ
เรียนชอบสีอะไร
ชอบสีเขียวค่ะสีเขียวเขียวๆนี่ไหมโอเคไหม
ๆๆโอเคค่ะใช้อ่ะเตรียมเตรียมเขียนได้หรือ
ยังได้แล้วค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราจับเวลานะคะอ่ะ 1 นาทีระวาดนะ
เอาเพราะไม่ยังสาวหิวข้าวเดียวค่ะ
Play
คู่เอกคู่เดิมหาปากกาปากกาใช่ไหมอ่ะ
หมอเวรต้องเป่าหัวหาย
ไหมคะวาดวาดว่าอะไรนะเบอร์ 3 บริษัท 3
เป็นห้างนะคะนักเรียนข้างพร้อมไหมคะครู
เลียม
เออ
ก็ไม่ออกแป๊บนึงนะคะ
ดอกติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อก Korea หาปากกาอยู่หา
ปากกาเจอไว้ปากกา
เรียมเจอปากกาไหมคะ
ต้องขยับ
ได้ไหมได้ไหมตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้น
her
เล่นมากๆบิ๊กต๊อกฟาเรซ่าอันนี้เป็นอะไร
คุณเรียนเป็นเส้นหรือเป็นปากกาเป็น
เราที่เป็นก็เป็นค่ะคูเรียมต้องไปสตาร์
ได้โอเคโอเคได้แล้วนะคะพรุ่งนี้ไม่เอาสี
เขียวนะคะเรียนสีเขียวคู๋เอาเอาสีซิสี
ฟ้า
เก๋
อ่ะยาสีฟ้านะคะ
ราคาพี่เอ๋
โอเคงั้นพร้อมนะคู่เตรียมพร้อมค่ะห้าง
ข้างมีอะไรครูเรียม 1 นาทีนะคะวาดเลยค่ะ
ไม่ดูกันนะคะครูเอ๋ไม่ดูครูเรียมโคเรียม
ไม่ดูเองโอเคไหม
คู่เทียมวาดแล้ว
เดี๋ยวใจเย็นโอเคโอเค
สามสองหนึ่งไปเลย
พี่ติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อก
r-cooh เรียม
คู๋ว่านอะไรคู่เอกวันอะไรนักเรียนดูพระ
เอกว่าวัดอะไรเนี่ย
โคเอกว่าอะไรครูเรียมว่าอะไร
เรียกว่าลายล่ะครูเรียกว่าอะไรคุยดูไม่
ได้คู๋ด้วยตัวเองกูเองไม่ดูกูไอ้หนูของ
ตัวเองมีอะไรอ่ะ
กูเองว่าอะไรวะเนี่ย
มีอะไรมีอะไรเอาเม็ดไก่โอเคอ่ะอ่ะ
this  App ถอดเวลาโคเรียว
เดี๋ยวกูเลี้ยงอ้าว่าได้อะไรวะเนี่ย 1
นาทีล่ะอร่อยว่างเดี๋ยวดูของตัวเอกอ่อนนะ
คะโพเรียมโหให้ถูกไหมกูอันที่ 1 ได้ตู้
เย็นปออโต้เย็นนักเรียนตู้เย็นเวลามีมี
น้ำใช่ไหมน้ำเราก็เปิดตู้เย็นแล้วก็ใส่
ตู้เย็นนะก็ปิดอ่ะตู้เย็นเวนะได้หนึ่ง
แล้วนะค่าของ
ทีวี
โอเคมั้ย
โลเทคมากเลยมีมีหนวดกุ้งดี
ทีวีนะคะ
ผู้ชาย
เออ 4
ผู้หญิง
555 เด็ก on เด็กตัวเล็กๆๆเด็กหญิง
เอก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
กระโปรงกระโปรงผู้หญิงกระโปรงของผู้หญิง
นะคะ
ต่อไปเจ็บ
7 เสื้อเสื้อ
ต่อไป 8
กางเกงวัดสวยหน่อยอ่ากางเกงขายาวกางเกงขา
ยาว
ก้าว
ซ่อม
น้อง
ส้ม
กินข้าวกินสปาเก็ตตี้นะคะ 10 ช้อน
นะคะ
11 แก้ว
เต็มแก้ว
โอเคแก้ว
12 เหมือนไหมอ่ะอะไรคะครูเอ๋
12 เหรอ
ถุงเท้า
รองเท้า
ทุเรียนคิดถึงเท้าถุงเท้ามันต้องมีอันนี้
มันต้องมีแบบนี้อ๋อ
อันนี้ไม่มีก็จะเป็นรองเท้ารองเท้ารอง
เท้ากันฝนเวลาฝนตกเฮ้อแล้วก็ 13 โอเคไหม
ดูรู้เรื่องไหมเนี่ยไก่
ไก่
เห้ยไก่อยู่ในห้างคู๋ไว้ไก่ที่ไม่มีขนไม่
เป็นไงเนี่ยไก่ไก่หนึ่งตัว
กูอีกทำไมไก่อยู่ในห้างตุ๊กตาไก่ก็
มีนะมีร้านตุ๊กตาไก่เคยเห็นอ่าตุ๊กตา
Toy ๆอะไรพวกเนี่ยมีตุ๊กตาไก่
เองไหมโอเคไหมโอเคไหมคะ 13 เนี่ย 13
เนี้ย 13 ไก่เกิดโอเคมั้ยกูเตรียมคิดว่า
ไม่โอเคบ้านอยู่ที่บ้าน
มีว่าอยู่นะ
จริงๆกูเอกคิดมากวัดไก่อย่างนี้ค่ะอะไรนะ
ค่ะอันเนี้ย
ไก่แต่ว่าครูควรนักเรียนคิดเป็นไมโครโฟน
กูเองก็เลยว่าไก่เนี่ยไก่ที่กินชาใช่ระหา
ๆไก่โอเคดูเองว่าได้ 10
13 รูปให้เรียบครูเรียมว่าอะไรมี
คู่เดียวหมู่บ้านฮือ
เรียบเรียงมีอะไรบ้างอ่ะเดี๋ยวกูเอาดูนะ
อ่ะกูเห็นหนึ่งละเสื้อ
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้คืออะไรคะกิน Number ก็ได้
ค่ะคุณเรียม
หนึ่งฉันหนึ่งค่ะโอ้เอง
อาณา
โอเคได้ฉันที่ 1
[เพลง]
มีอะไรอีกคะ 2 อันนี้มีชั้นที่ 2 ค่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
โอเคฉันที่ 2
ใช่มีอะไรอีกเค้ามีบันไดเลื่อนเอาบันได
เลื่อนเป็น 3 นะคะใบเลื่อนค่ะอ่ะถ้ามี
อะไรอีกนี่ลิป 10 สี
ลิปอาร์โต้ในห้างของครูเรียมมีเสื้ออา
เสื้อเป็น 5 นะคะ
มีกางเกงพบ
กางเกงกางเกงขายาว
ค่ะ
ขายขายาวชายใช่ค่ะแล้วก็มีอะไรอ่ะมี
ราว
เราจับเราจับอ้ะมีอีกไหม
ไม่มี
โอ้โหโหล
โอเคเกมที่ 1 คู๋ชนะๆได้ค่ะเจ้าไปก่อนเกม
ที่ 1 อันนี้หายไปไหนวะต้องเรา
อ๋อ
โอเคอันนี้ก็ครูเรียม
โคเรียมอ่ะแล้วแบ่งครึ่งนะคะครูเรียม
ได้ 77
โอเรียมว่าได้ 7 รูปครูเอ๋ได้
13r นะโอเคกูเลี้ยงม.ค
เกมส์ที่สองครูเอ๋เลือกนะคะค่ะเรือ
เลือกเลยนะคะ
ขวากับซ้ายกูเอาสายอ่ะมี
สายอ่ะสายแล้วก็มีหนึ่งเห็นไหม
เห็นไหมคะ 1 ขวาอ่าตารางแล้วก็สาย
เก่งสาย
เห็นไหมใกล้ไปที่ไหน
โอเคเห็นค่ะเห็นนะเรียมจ๋าคว้า
กลางซ้ายคู๋เรื่องซ้าย 5
เดี๋ยวมาดูนะคะจะเป็นเบอร์อะไรคู๋เนี่ย
คิดเบอร์ 5 ทะเลทะเลลูกเอ๋ชอบทะเลหรอคะๆ
กูเอ๋ชอบทะเลเบอร์ 5 งูนะคะคิดคิดเบอร์
อะไร
เบอร์ 4  5
มีเพื่อนฟรี
เปิดเรอะเปิด
เฮ้ยทุเรียนเชียร์เบอร์อะไรนะคะเบอร์ 4
ค่ะ 555  4 ใช่มั้ย 4545 เย้
ไม่มีไม่มีเสียงอะไร
ทุเรียนมีเสียงอะไรที่บ้านใช่ไหมคู่ทีม
ได้ยินเสียงเสียงเหมือนท่อน้ำ
อ้าวท่อน้ำ
เลี้ยงทำไมดูไม่จะไปรู้ไหม
จะดูไหมคะเดี๋ยวครูเรียมไปดู 1 นะคะให้ดู
แล้วไม่ได้ค่ะ
เบอร์ 5 ค่ะครูเรียมโหฉันเลนักเรียนถา
ทะเลค่ะมาเลย์เบอร์
โอ้ทะเลมีอะไร
ทะเลมีอะไรโคเรียม
เราแบ่งครึ่ง
[เพลง]
รู้สึกเดี๋ยวนะคะของคุณเรียนจะน้อยไปไหม
อยากให้คุณเรียนไปเถอะ
ขอบคุณค่ะ
OK พอไหมคะพร้อมให้คุณเรียง
ร้องค่ะ 3  2  1 โอเคค่ะอันนี้เอ๋นะคะคู๋
อ้าห้องดูเอกเขียนชื่อก่อนอ่ะได้ค่ะว่า
ได้เลยค่ะ 3 ซอง
ทะเลมีอะไรอ่ะหนึ่งนาทีนะคะครูเรียมอำนวย
พี่ติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กตอกมีอะไรมีอะไรนักเรียน
ช่วยคิดนะคะว่ามีอะไรบ้างที่ทะเลนักเรียน
ช่วยกันรุ่ยรังเส้น
กูเนี้ยวันนี้ของครูเอ๋อ่า
จะนะคะ
ล่างทุเรียนว่าอะไรคุยว่าอะไร
ป๋ามมีอะไรอีก 3
1 หมดเวลา
อะไรนะก็ไม่รู้เรียง
โอ้
โห้โย้โห้กูเลียมวัดเยอะเลยเดี๋ยวดูมี
อะไรบ้าง
ๆได้ค่ะของคู่เตรียมว่าอะไรคะนักเรียนดู
ดวง
โอเคมีทรายในค่ะอันไหนคะทรายไง
ตายขอทรายทราย
ทรายน่าจะเป็นสีสีน้ำตาลน้ำตาลไม่ใช่ล่ะ
สีเหลืองก็ได้เนาะน้ำตาลก็ออกจาก
ให้
สาวชายหาดทรายค่ะ
แล้ว 2 ค่ะครูเรียม
ปู
คูเรียมปูกูเลี้ยงโดนตา
ตา
ก้ามปูไปไหน
มีขากู
อีกด้วยนะคะคุณเรียม
ได้ค่ะอ่ะ
กูมีขาเพิ่มขึ้น
งาม
อาจมีตาโอเคค่ะ 2 ปู 3 ค่ะ
3  Two ชาย
ผู้ชายโอเคค่ะ
4 ค่ะ 4 ผู้หญิง
4 ผู้หญิงค่ะ 5 ค่ะ
ลาดาว prod เอาอ๋อ
คนไทยแล้วโอ้โหเห็นเป็นปลาดาวไหมคะที่
เห็นค่ะเห็นเป็นปลาดาวแต่ว่าครูเอกแค่
สงสัย
ว่าดาว
ทำไมอยู่มันอยู่บนหาดทรายโอ๊ยตายแล้วหรอ
คะไม่ค่ะปลาดาวอยู่บนหาดทรายได้ก็ได้นะ
ปลาร้าซาวด์โอเคค่ะ 5 ปลาดาว 6 ค่ะ 6
ลูกมะพร้าวดาวมะนาวค่ะดาว
อย่าบอกว่าเจ็ดขึ้นต้นมะพร้าวนะคะ
อ่ะมะพร้าว ago  a ช่วย
อันนี้เป็นอันนี้เป็นลูกมะพร้าว
ได้ค่ะใช่ค่ะ
6  6 ลูกๆ
7 ค่า
ต้นมะพร้าว
a8 ค่ะ
8 หอยหอยหอยหอย 9 อีดอกข่า 9  of ๆให้กู
อีกเราไหมอันนี้มั้ยติดเตียงที่นั่งใช่
ค่ะนั่งเก้าอี้เก้าอี้ชายหาด 5  9 คุย
ช่วยว่า
เก้าอี้ชายหาดมีขาตรงนี้เนาะใช่ค่ะแบบคน
นั่งที่นี่ได้ใช่สิบร่มใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะ
ร่มๆนะกินช่วยครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋ดูนะอะไร
กูเหลี่ยมวาดรูปเก่งใช่ไหมคะ
โอเคช่วย
ร่มนะคะอ่ะ 11 ค่ะ
ลา
51 ปลาปลาตัวเล็กมากนะฮะอันนี้ตาหน่อย
นี่ตาไหนเอาปลามีตามีครีบอ่ะมีแค่อยากปลา
สิบสองค่ะ 12
น้ำทะเล
น้ำน้ำทะเล
13 ค่ะ
อันนี้สึก 3 คลื่น
เค
คืนนะคะหรือพื้น
กูเองว่าจะว่างขึ้นแล้วลืม
สิบสี่ค่ะ 14 เรือ 14 อะเรือ
15 ค่ะอุด 5
พระอาทิตย์พระอาทิตย์นะคะอ่าพระอาทิตย์
คูเรียมได้ 15 รูป
โอ้โห
เก่งมาก
ขอบคุณค่ะขอบคุณค่ะได้กี่ลูกของครูเอ๋ได้
เลยนะลูก
หนึ่ง
ต้นมะพร้าว
เหมือนโคเรียมมีต้นมะพร้าวนะคะ
2 ค่าโคเรียมอะไรรู้ไหม
คู่เตรียมคิดว่า
นกใช่นกฆ่า
นกราคา 3 ค่ากูเรียม
ก็นี่ให้ถามแม่แม่ฮะแม่ก็จะสี
หรือป๊าอะไรสิเฒ่าๆๆ
เติมให้นักเรียนบอกไม่เติมเข้าใจง่ายกว่า
อ่ะ
ฮะโอเคเมฆค่ะ 4 หักโคเรียมอะไรเอ่ย
ดวงอาทิตย์ดวงอาทิตย์นะคะอ่ะโดนอาทิตย์
พระอาทิตย์โอเคนะคะต่อไป
555 ผู้ชาย
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิง
เจ็บ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋
บิกินี่ชุดว่ายน้ำข้างหมด
ชุดว่ายน้ำๆมีข้างบนแล้วก็ข้างล่าง 8
เย็นโหโอเคไหมหรือ 1 รวมเป็นหนึ่งโอเค
โอเคโอเคได้อะไร
แล้วก็ 999
ที่ 9 เรือใบ
เรือใบ 10
ทะเล
ทะเลทะเลนะคะ
11oz สิบเหมือนครูเรียมทะเล 11 ปูปู
โอมเหมือนคูเรียมนะคะ
12 มึงคิดว่ามึงอีกมึงๆเหมือนไหมหมึก
เหมือนค่ะเหมือนหมึกนะคะ 12 ราคาอร่อย
ศึก 3 คู่เรียมดูเข้าใจไหมเนี่ย
อะไรนักเรียนคิดว่าครูเอ๋วาดอะไรคะอะไรคะ
เติมขาวโอ๊ย
โอ๊ย
กุ้ง
ไส้กุ้ง 13 กุ้งค่ะ
แล้วก็ 14 ถ้ากูเรียกไม่ถ้าว่าเท่ากัน
เหรอเนี้ย 14 อะไรคะ
ปลา
กูเทียมคิดว่าหอยแล้วหรอป้า
ปลาครูเลียมกับปลาคุ่ดูไม่เหมือนปลานะ
แล้วก็ 15 อะไรเอ่ย
ถ้า
อะไรอะไรเหมือนของคุณเรียมค่ะมีคนนั่งที่
นี่ได้อ๋อ
[เพลง]
เกาลัดเก้าอี้ชายหาดจริงๆอันนี้มัน 16
ไม่ได้เพราะมันเหมือนท่าเรือ
ก็กูเอร์ก็ได้
45  roo ย
โอ้ยโอ้โห Korea คะโอ้วันนี้นักเรียนน่ะ
รู้จักสองที่เนาะที่แห้งมีอะไรเราให้พ่อ
ที่ทะเลมีลมแต่ว่า
เวลา
เวลาหมดเวลาหมดแล้ว
ยังมีอีกกูเสียดายเนาะคู่เทียมยากว่าวาด
ว่าอีกก็อยากว่านอีกหรอโอ้ยนักเรียนอย่าง
ว่านกับครูเรียนไหมหานักเรียนอยากว่ากับ
ครูเรียมนะคะก็ต้องมีอีเมล์ติดต่อครู
เรียมไว้เรียน
นะคะผู้เรียนชอบวาดรูปกับเรานะคะเราติด
ต่อบ่ได้เนาะใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋มีช่อง
ยูทูปช่องอะไรคะอ๋อครู ami ถ่าย
conversation  Cafe ค่ะอ๋อกูหรือว่านัก
เรียนอยากดูโคเรียมก็อยู่ในช่องยูทูป
เตรียมไทยนะคะค่ะหรือว่ามาขอพิเศษที่ว่า
ใครก็ได้เนาะอ่าขา 2 ช่องราคา
โอเควันนี้เราหมดวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้ววันนี้
นักเรียนก็รู้จักทะเลใช่ไหมคะเปิด 5 ทะเล
แล้วก็ห้าง
มีอะไรจะนะคะอ่าใช่ทะเลมีอะไรแล้วก็ห้าง
มีอะไรนะคะถ้าขอคู่เรียนกับครูเอกต้องไปๆ
แล้วใช่ค่ะแล้วมาเจอ
เต็มเปี่ยมกับครูเอ๋เอ๋ในคลิปหน้านะคะ
โอเคค่ะเป็นไรวันนี้ขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียนสวัสดีค่ะทุก
คนไม่วายสวัสดีค่ะไม่ว่าจะ